I'm Dean Oliver former assistant coach
for the Washington Wizards and a
statistical analyst for sports I'm here
to answer your questions from the
internet this is sports math
[Music]
sport first up at FW 1027 what is the
most efficient shot in basketball the
most efficient shot in basketball is the
layup any shot around the rim getting to
the rim not only is a higher percentage
shot it will more likely get you to the
foul line which players make about 75 to
80% the second most important shot is
any shot beyond the three-point Arc
anything out
here shots out here are made at about
35% but because of the extra point
awarded for being Beyond The Ark they
are more efficient at NBA
aded statistically speaking who is
better Jordan or LeBron frankly Michael
Jordan was probably a little bit better
Defender LeBron is is a little bit
better passer than Michael Jordan was
LeBron adopted also the three-point shot
a lot earlier than Michael Jordan did
but all in all they are almost the same
at wmax asks what studies do you do to
become a sports statistician that is a
good question this did not exist when I
was a kid having a career where you get
to do math in sports is a great
innovation of the 21st century that
being said it's not the easiest thing to
get into anymore in order to do it you
really need to know sports for sure
sometimes people forget that but you
also need to know things like
programming with a language like python
you need to know things about statistics
basic statistics or a little bit more
advanced that will only help you because
this is an
interdisciplinary job you need to know
how to communicate it you need to know
how to communicate math to sports people
and you need to know how to communicate
Sports to math people from Ravens
realist what is the most important
quarterback back stat the longest one in
existence is the pass a rating that one
goes back 50 years it is a very simple
metric that just evaluates four
categories of touchdowns yards
completion percentage and interceptions
it's not great a better one is coming
from ESPN which is called qbr which
accounts for what is more important in
modern NFL which is the running
quarterback which is avoiding sacks the
traditional stat that people probably
latch on to the most is quarterback
completion percentage of the more
traditional stats completion percentage
correlates the best with success but
it's still not as good as something like
qbr at on re asked bro why are there so
many no hitters now the bottom line for
there being more no hitters is that over
the last 10 to 15 years batting averages
are down there are multiple reasons for
this one of them is the shift in
baseball they allowed a shift of
fielders to go basically wherever you
wanted to when they studied the data
they knew that some players hit the ball
in certain areas more so if you put more
fielders in that area you get more outs
as of this season 2023 the shift was
made illegal to limit some of the
ability of a defense to shut down a
hitter the other reason probably they
manage pitchers differently the pitchers
don't go and throw a complete Game
nearly as much as they did so you're
seeing a lot more combined no hitters 20
years ago that wasn't happening near as
much it was all one pitcher doing the
whole thing when you have multiple
pitchers they come in they're fresh they
have a better chance to shut down a
hitter moving on at Max Sports Studio
asks hypothetical a player is filed at
the buzzer he gets to shoot two free
throws his team is down by one is the
probability that he makes the second
shot affected by the outcome of the
first free throw first of all the first
free throw is usually much harder
players haven't been able to dial in
their depth perception there's also this
thought that their heartbeat is probably
a little bit faster because the action
is kind of calming down usually it's
easier to make the ones after that but
in this situation where the pressure is
on players do react very differently
under pressure and there have been
studies that have shown free throw
shooters who are under pressure they do
shoot worse by 5 to 10% ATK online asked
does defense really win championships in
basketball in particular what you see is
that offense carries teams through the
regular season what happens when you get
to the playoffs is the best teams know
how to ramp up their defense they are
playing better offensive teams but they
know how to strategically defend those
teams take away the best players that is
the way in which you see defense winning
championships defense doesn't win
championships on its own next up qua
user asks how is Messi better than
Ronaldo in stats the best measure we
have for soccer performance for
individuals is goals it is not the best
thing that could be developed but over
the years that Messi and Ronaldo played
it is what we have at Nikki numbers asks
did you know that former Yankee
shortstop Derek Jeter was a below
average Fielder the numbers prove it
Derek Jeter was not as good as his
reputation because some of the stats
said that he gave up a lot of extra runs
on top of what other Short Stops would
do won five gold gloves because when he
got to a ball he was pretty good at
making the right throw making the right
read but his ability to get to the ball
was much more limited his range was
limited and that mattered a lot at K
tizzle 512 how exactly is an NFL spread
calculated and what all goes into
calculating the spread there is a lot of
mathematical calculation that goes into
a spread including what players are
going to be available where the game is
going to be played whether the weather
is going to matter wind rain all of
those sorts of things who the refereeing
crew is going to be all of these things
have Tendencies for affecting the spread
that is how an initial line can be set
but what happens because the NFL has bet
so much a lot of the gambling houses is
they just try to split the pot so at the
end they're just trying to make sure
they have 50% of the people on one side
of line and 50% on the other side at
Elite dog3 asked what is true shooting
percentage I've been hearing it but what
is the official way to calculate it true
shooting percentage is just
total points scored by a player or a
team divided by the shot attempts
they've taken which is a combination of
field goal attempts from the field and a
fraction of their free throw attempts
it's more representative of the actual
contribution of a player because it
captures how many points a player is
getting from their field goal attempts
so if they're shooting a lot from three
it's capturing that efficiency over
someone who takes a lot of twos and it's
capturing their ability to get to the
foul line which can be enormous for
players players like Jimmy Butler or
Giannis or Lebron a Miller 10 asks when
are stupid ass people going to realize
that pitcher wins are a meaningless stat
that shouldn't be used to decide
anything a pitcher win loss record
actually tells you something which is
winning and avoiding losing but it
doesn't get at all the details very well
for what a pitcher is doing it doesn't
get at their ability to throw strikes it
doesn't get their ability to limit the
opposing team's hitters so it's missing
important details but it's getting it
something important at DMC have running
backs ever been less valued in NFL
history it is true right now that NFL
running backs are being devalued
probably rightly so whether they've gone
past where they're getting devalued too
much I don't know the reason they are
getting devalued is because we're
recognizing that the offensive line
matters a lot in how many yards those
running backs get so the credit that
those guys used to to get as Superstars
they're not getting quite as much of as
they used to so yes they are getting
devalued and probably rightly so moving
on at King DJ
5297 I'm supposed to believe that
advanced stats work for the NBA yes
Advanced stats work for the NBA probably
better than other sports for instance
there are team offensive ratings and
team defensive ratings which are how
many points a team scores and allows per
100 possessions that is a very accurate
representation of how good an offense or
a defense is the NFL has maybe 14 drives
for a team in a game baseball has maybe
40 at bats in basketball you have
probably 80 possessions where you have
the best players able to touch the ball
and able to shoot the ball so you get a
very good representation of how good
teams are at dah black you can measure
nearly everything statistically how do
you statistically measure an offensive
guard in football I presume in the NFL
we have an immense amount of data that
tracks where all the players are on the
field at every point in time which
direction they're facing and so forth
with all of this data now you can
actually measure how well offensive
guards for instance block how well can
they win the block against the defensive
player keeping that defensive player
from getting either to a running back or
to a quarterback from IC at Nola Legend
assists are the most overrated stats in
basketball when will people understand
this assists in the MBI are probably
given out too easily they give them for
very simple passes but they also give
them four more difficult passes the
players who get a lot of the easy
assists are probably overrated but the
ones who have the passes for the alley
oops for the layups the ones in
transition those are very valuable I
wouldn't call them overrated as a stat
but I would say that some of the players
who get assists are overrated at rzn 2
blv ask did Bill James and Billy Bean
change the game of baseball Bill James
did it by writing a book multiple books
in fact called the baseball abstracts
which got read by a lot of fans and then
eventually by people working in baseball
like the general manager of the Oakland
A's Billy Bean the game of baseball like
a lot of sports actually is about
identifying the best players and how to
put them in the best position to succeed
what they used is data to help make
those decisions a particular statistic
that they recognized as undervalued was
walks or on base percentage the fact
that walks get you on base on top of
getting a base hit is something that was
not appreciated by traditional Major
League Baseball they did that behind the
scen and gained a major advantage next
up Reddit user 360 asks what statistics
are most important in the NBA it's not
things like points and rebounds and
turnovers and assists it is offensive
rating and defensive rating points a
team scores and allows per 100
possessions beyond that when you're
trying to understand what a team is
doing to be efficient on either side of
the basketball most important things are
what called the four factors and the
four factors are how well you shoot
which is an effective field goal
percentage which weights three-point
shots more than two-point shots a
turnover percentage an offensive
rebounding percentage and then how often
you get to the line those four things
will tell you why an offense or a
defense is efficient act vaguely
artistic if the triangle is such a
simple shape why can't anyone explain
the triangle offense I'm not going to
explain the triangle offense here I can
tell you that the triangle offense is
successful only with a couple coaches
frankly it's it was successful with Phil
Jackson with the bulls and with the
Lakers you are creating good shots for
good players and good shots for even
average players who are there to set
screens and just play off the ball and
what it does is it relies upon the
strengths of the player
themselves to make decisions this is a
good one eh hoichi is Red Zone
efficiency a good efficiency stat the
Red Zone efficiency is how well an
offense does within the last 20 yards of
the field Red Zone efficiency is useful
it is uh predictive to some degree and
it explains the success of teams teams
that are very good at it they will be
better offenses and teams that are bad
they will be worse but is it perfect no
just like pretty much every other NFL
statistic moving on at it's a coal World
26 asks what's the most important stat
for a receiver catches if you're going
to use very simple metrics are the best
representation of a receiver's ability
it is not the best metric when you start
including the analytical stats we have a
lot better information on drops for
instance for receivers how difficult the
catch is where the ball was whether they
had to pull it in there are better stats
for that but it's a complex series of
them there's not a simple metric at this
point for overall wide receiver ability
that's all the questions we have for
sports math till next
[Music]
time